non monsieur bancaire alors tu arrêtes
de tous j'en ai peur le kit gris
s'arracher le gosier est ce qu'ils sont
vraiment aussi bête que les reins aux
français c'est pas trop intelligent et
passe à la télé on imagine comme animal
est ce que c'est quand même assez
intelligent pour savoir s'occuper de ses
propres intérêts oui c'est assez serré
mais c'est l'animal savall a été
découverte en amérique n'est pas habitué
au temps que les autres à
d'investigation et ils vont s'en verront
bien évident à les dépouilles
par contre il retrouvé travail alors je
veux dire par exemple fonctionne en
régie à wissant cannibales et sans trop
gentil attentionné maussade ils vont
s'arranger sur la rose a annoncé entre
nous je veux pas vous décourager
tiendront de l'animal choisi de 8 à 6 il
est tombé le 20 je veux dire est ce trop
demander des soins bien particulier en
france une mission venue de nos jours on
à frire ou lite est bien balancé à et
les mains d'un lot de troupes qu'on
avait des rats vont avoir des belles
bêtes comme ce que vous avez dit l'hôtel
logeant le ballon avant la chair on a
confirmation pour ça est ce que mon
affection me nourrir nous saouler
sélectionné déjà pas la sélection ce
qu'on a fait pendant des années quand on
est parvenu à voir ça fait rire vous
choisissez beaucoup à présent choisi
militants les propriétaires ont regardé
la rencontre
c'est lent
on attache un gros talent a maintenant
écoutez je vais encore demandé
deuxièmement je crois que vous avez
invité à goûter une moderne ça
m'enchante invitation et en dépit d'un
appétit oui ça creuse l'enfance en
disant quand je pense au match opposant
je m'en allais travail
non c'est pas ses patins
c'est pas les pierres que vous gardez
pour vous même je pense aux noms dont la
forme dont vous parliez la disent qu'il
faut les gens vont dire par même temps
de la carcasse fortis et ça voulait dire
oui si vous voyez et puis le petit panda
vient gars dans la couleur oui
certainement au cuit au four de la bonne
manière d'avoir basculé alors venir à
bout ça faisait trop s'inquiéter en
venir à bout
chez paquet vont passer de moi je pense
d'autres outils